overwatch has received plenty of updates
since its may release but its biggest
batch of new cosmetic items just dropped
this Friday is the kickoff of the 2016
olympic games in rio an overwatch is
celebrating in style starting today you
can grab all the new stuff and hop into
a brand new game mode the new game mode
is called Lucio ball two teams of
Lucio's use his boost and sound wave
abilities to knock a ball into the goal
sort of like rocket League but the bulk
of new content comes from the limited
edition Summer Games loot boxes these
contain skins like track and field
tracer in weightlifting zaria plus new
sprays player icons victory poses and
voice lines you'll get one free box when
you log on and you can earn more by
playing the game or purchasing them from
the store as usual over watches summer
games update will run through August
22nd on all platforms Blizzard says more
seasonal updates are on the way so
fingers crossed for a Santa Claus
torbjörn this holiday season to keep up
with all the latest from overwatch stay
grouped up with gamespot